[Música]
fuera netanyahu así corean miles de
manifestantes frente a la residencia del
primer ministro israelí a pocos días de
las elecciones legislativas del martes
estamos aquí para protestar contra
netanyahu y su gobierno corrupto esta es
nuestra última oportunidad antes de las
elecciones queremos que todo el mundo
salga a votar
tras 12 años en el poder los comicios
del martes podrían poner fin a su
mandato y para el hombre que detenta el
récord de longevidad al mando del
gobierno
la apuesta es alta pero benjamín
netanyahu está siendo procesado por
corrupción fraude y abuso de confianza
en tres casos su condición de líder no
le protege por el momento pero espera
ganar la mayoría de los escaños para
quizás obtener la inmunidad judicial más
adelante otro tema de descontento entre
la población israelí es su gestión de la
crisis actual la oposición denuncia la
insuficiencia de ayudas para los
trabajadores que han perdido su empleo
por la pandemia
benjamin netanyahu por su parte pretende
ganar votos gracias al éxito de su
campaña de vacunación vamos bien eso es
todo
solo tenemos que vacunar a unos cientos
de miles de personas más sobre todo a
los mayores de 50 años y habremos
terminado con la primera fase será el
final de todo eso si bien el likud el
partido de centroderecha de benjamin
netanyahu parece estar a la cabeza de
las encuestas no es seguro que pueda
formar una mayoría en él